do you know what the first battle of the
Civil War
was Suter or Suter yeah how many people
died at Suter not very I think there was
one and you know how he died did he fall
on his own it was an accident some kind
of accident happened do you know what
the first actual armed conflict of the
Civil War was it's Harper's fery First
Battle of Bull Run man Manasses and we
historically say Sumpter was the start
of the Civil War however after Sumpter
the people of the United States did not
believe a civil war was happening or
even could happen so when the troops
were amassing in Manasses local
residents went to have picnics on the
hilltop to watch and it was bedum when
the Union and Confederate soldiers
started shooting at each other and
people were getting their guts blown out
and cannon fire was ripping them apart
and the funny thing is if the
Confederacy marched on DC at that moment
the South would have won the war in an
instant but the Confederacy believed
that by repelling the Union forces the
war was over and they have asserted
themselves by doing so the union would
back down instead as the Confederacy
backed off the union doubled its forces
called for conscription and then
deployed shitloads of people to go back
and invade the self uh your points about
normaly bias and optimism bias or
however you put it are well taken but
here's where I come from I don't come
from it from either of those points of
view I come from it as these people are
all Republican Governors Democrat
presidents these are all people who are
high up in the system these people do
not sit around like we do at night and
stress to no end about the culture and
America and what's happening they just
don't they don't they'll pretend like
like they do for the cameras but they
don't and so you're asking people or
you're thinking people who are not true
believers will start conducting
themselves as if they are True Believers
that is my point my point is in the end
both for Abbott and Joe Biden what
really benefits them in the end is you
drive some donations you re you rev up
the base and in the end you kind of work
something out where you both look okay
because look Biden's already got his
Revolution he already owns the Federal
Government he he has it all Abbot is the
governor of the second most powerful
state in the country he's doing just
fine too these people are not going to
risk their position to escalate things
no donations the page that he posted now
that says something right now that says
something I I don't know that I
completely agree the issue right now is
that Joe Biden's popularity is in like
the mid-30s and so it may be that these
Governors are thinking yeah there's not
going to be a civil war but the winning
side of the donations and the political
stature is going to be opposing Joe
Biden maybe well back to what we were
talking about and I I remember everyone
remembers everyone remembers the
propaganda from covid right we don't
have to go over all that and get the
endless amounts from everywhere from
doctors media politicians all of them
everyone remembers the endless covid
propaganda right again I keep coming
back to this what if something bad
happens on the border what if someone
gets killed what if someone gets hurt
bad what if it's a kid or or or a woman
can you imagine what the propaganda
campaign would do it would be George
Floy on steroids if somebody gets hurt
down there the campaign they would wage
against the right would be bad and I'm
not saying I don't I love everything
they're doing I'm saying we are entering
a territory that is fraught with risk
Frau with risk because of the country
itself I got one more for you what if
someone makes a very believable but kind
of grainy deep fake of a CBP agent
opening fire on the National Guard yeah
MH and several of them what happens if
several vice versa National Guard back
the other way so there's this video that
we talked about in the culture war of
MH370 it's not really it's a video of a
plane in the sky with orbs circling
around it and then it just disappears it
goes and it went it it was published on
YouTube like 3 months after MH370
vanished didn't say it was MH370 but
everyone thought it was and now people
believe it's a real video Even though
there's other people who have like
debunked it and said here's where this
CGI graphic was came from came from this
video
game the one of the reason people
believe it is because there's multiple
there's two angles two different videos
and it's a it's filming a screen so what
if someone made this video of a border
conflict and they CG rendered perfectly
using Unreal Engine or something
H holy dude have you seen unal have
you seen have you seen the current
unreal I was at Best Buy the other day
cuz we were buying TVs for the new
studio and it was a video of a guy parah
Paris skiing I guess you call it they've
they've got those guys are nuts they've
got skis on and they're skiing with the
parachute and then they pull up and they
can jump and then I'm like I think it's
fake I I'm yeah that's got to be CGI but
it's kind of hard to tell what if
someone makes multiple angles of the
same thing and it looks like the
fighting's
begun what happens when Greg Abbott sees
that video and says get me info on
what's going on I mean I
look let me tell you how how nightmarish
and precarious all of this could be one
person building a machine requires
shitloads of people from managerial
expertise resource acquisition
engineering Etc and one dumb
can throw a Tech Deck into
it and break the whole thing M the same
is true for this country and I don't
want to explain
exactly I I I wouldn't want to say
exactly how because it's but let me just
say the Deep fake thing combined with
one other technique that is easily
available to the public I guarantee 100%
would result in a civil war happening
tomorrow I don't want to say say what
that is I disagree uh I can't I can't
say what it is whatever the technique is
and here's why here's why I disagree the
American people are so apathetic that
25% of the Republicans even show up in
primaries you can't get people to vote
in a primary but they're going to take
how many people fought the American
Revolution no way third of the country
3% really yeah
estimated 3% were the were the Armed
Forces who actually F oh the Armed
Forces yeah 30% of the country was on
the side of the revolutionaries 30% of
them are loyalists 30% of sat out the
whole thing that's actually that's that
that was a that was a uh uh that letter
about 3030 and 30 was actually a guess
it wasn't correct the estimates are that
it was like
28% revolutionary sentiment was actually
really high relatively high but it was
not 5050 it was in the in the high 40s I
believe and then the don't care we like
in the 20s or whatever it's very
Regional too right between the North and
the South and everything else yep lot of
loyalists in the north yeah so the issue
with Civil War and this is this is again
a mistake a lot of people make when it
comes to war is they assume that Wars
are fought by everybody when in fact
every single war in the history of the
world has been fought by almost nobody
well Civil Wars they are though and
Civil Wars I wish they Civil Wars are
felt by everyone in a nation they're
felt brutally by everyone in a nation
they're really really bad and they
should be avoided at all costs and uh uh
so how many do you how many police
officers are in New York no third
largest army in the world 30 to 40,000 I
believe police officers with onethird of
them being support staff how many people
live on Manhattan Island
like eight million or something 2.5
million yeah not not eight million it's
it's it went down I think to two million
or whatever when everyone fled because
of covid but um with the Burrows
included New York goes up to like nine
and then with the greater Metro which
includes Connecticut and stuff I think
you to 13 uh but let's talk about
Manhattan Island because of the police
forces that are there they're split up
with Brooklyn with Queens Long Island
Etc so uh well I queens and Brooklyn are
on Long Island I guess so we wouldn't
include Long Long Island in in New York
City let's say St Staten Island uh
Brooklyn Queens the Bronx uh Manhattan
what's who am I forgetting Brooklyn
Queens the Bronx Staten Island Brooklyn
clean Manhattan Manhattan
uh what
percentage of Manhattan is required to
be in protest to shut down the NYPD in
its
entirety five yeah 10 I that's a little
high 200,000 people no 2% could do it I
mean if you if you well it depends on
how you deployed them are we talking
about some Riot or some organized group
here so you've got 2 million people on
Manhattan 2% is 40,000 people the NYPD
is done if 2% of of Manhattan feels such
anger that they go out and March and
smash and Destroy there is nothing that
can stop them they call the National
Guard set up perimeters and have to use
Advanced weapons crowd control
techniques to try and stop such a
massive crowd of 40 get people killed
cuz eventually that would you'd have to
start shooting and that would be
horrible now you got them shooting
people let's talk about
4% let's just say
5% so now we're talking about 100,000
people just 5% of the population if just
5% of Manhattan decided that the NYPD
was corrupt racist pieces of and
they should go down and shut down
capitalism there is nothing in the
United States no amount of force that
could stop it there is no us Armed
Forces they could theoretically You
could argue they could send the Army in
with a bunch of guns but I do not
believe the US would be able to deploy
enough forces into New York to compete
with 100,000 marching angry people who
are violent but it wouldn't be it
wouldn't take place in Manhattan it
would you're not going to get people
involved in something as horrible it's a
civil war without somebody invading
that's that's the thing you're not they
not going to be an rising in man you
have to invade people in 2020 you should
have like it was pretty crazy in 2020
because NYPD stood we had the yeah the
NYPD stood down they were kneeling down
you had for the left they gave up they
gave up they were refusing to respond to
calls yeah they were refusing that that
was going on people were setting NYPD
vehicles on fire and since then New York
City has paid out a lot of those
protesters who set vehicles on fire and
stuff and you had um you had people
marching around through the street
causing all kinds of Mayhem the police
could not control the Looting they could
not control the protesters they couldn't
control it at all they just they just
couldn't they couldn't I understand the
point but the point the point Tim made
is not wrong I just mean if you're ever
going to have something as horrible God
forbid as a civil war in the country
it's not going to be an uprising in
Manhattan the only thing that would
prompt it would be the feds coming into
a red area to kick it off it would have
to be a physical compation the point of
this was you saying that 25% of
Republicans don't even go out and vote
or whatever and my point is this Texas
has 29.53 million people let's call it a
purple State cut that number in half and
just rounded it to about 15 million
Republicans let's
say 10% of them are upset with the
Border crisis and the illegal
immigration 1.5 million people let's say
10% of them are actually willing to
assist the state in dealing with the
problem which is now federal agents
150,000 people what would happen if 1%
of Republicans in Texas said Governor
Abbott tell us where to stand the
federal government is impotent and
Powerless and can do nothing there's no
amount of military force the feds would
be able to bring in to control that
there's no f-16s there's no nuclear
bombs they can make every argument they
want but there's a reason why we could
not win in Afghanistan and Vietnam
there's the reason why we we only got an
Armistice in
Korea large groups of people with
guns are the the principal force of any
of any armed faction and anybody who's
played any video game like Command and
Conquer or Warcraft or Starcraft
whatever whatever knows that one of the
best strategies is to mass-produce the
lowest level combat fighter and just
send wave after wave at your enemy and
overwhelm them there's no point like in
these video games like command and
conquer you can build up technology and
you can build nuclear bombs and you can
create tanks and then at some point some
guy was like I'm just going to keep
spamming infantry and I'm in MA Mass
produce infantry and America learned
that lesson Joe Biden's like you can't
go up against us cuz we got f-16s he
said it again recently sorry bro one
150,000 people in one area you can't
like your bombs will not stop that and
further anyone who knows um war strategy
Sops Etc knows if the Administration
took up active conflict against 150,000
people let's say 1% of that if the
bid Administration opened fire on, 1500
private citizen Texans who were
protesting and and demanding an answer
to the illegal immigration crisis you
would ignite a civil war overnight and
not because everyone says how dare you
attack Texas but much like the
southerners in the Civil War who fought
it's oh my God they're killing people I
have to defend my
home that's it the the so I I'll stress
this I will not say this on air there is
one simple technique available to every
single human in this country that could
be combined with deep fake technology
that I believe would absolutely result
in a civil war tomorrow and it is
rudimentary and it is simple and I will
not say it on air because of the risk
that someone actually tried to do
something like that I do not think
people are near angry enough yet in this
country I I see a country that uh look I
brought up Co every Co every covid
lockdown Governor mayor every co lo
lockd Downer got reelected every single
one of them every single one of them the
people ran out and voted for these
people again these are not of people who
are welling up with anger about tyranny
in the country think the people in
Atlanta in the Confederacy were ready to
go out into their streets and throw fire
bombs at their own Mayors your point is
it only has to be a small percentage
the people in Atlanta walked outside and
said hello brother I agree with you the
people across the country are the
problem so of course they elected all
the same people all over again when the
covid lockdowns happened the Democrats
were cheering well of course they they
they elected the same people all over
again yeah they liked it yeah so did
Republicans though they're still
Republicans at the same yeah but what in
like what Republican areas did they
accept all of it Mike dwine got
reelected easily sailed through his
Republican primary governor of very very
red accept very very red Ohio and
Republicans in Ohio went out
overwhelmingly voted men Greg Abbot look
he's all in the news right now Greg AB
it was awful during Co he wasn't Andrew
Cuomo he was awful during Co close your
bar I'll allow you do this I'll allow
you do that in the free state of Texas
ran out and he destroyed everybody he
had three very legitimate primary
opponents destroyed them I look I do not
see a people welling up with anger about
the tyranny in their country I do not
see it but that that's never been the
case how many antifa people do you how
many people do you think have antifa S
sentiments in the United
States probably not that many not that
many probably but what does that mean
give me a number 30,000 no way you mean
members or sentiments what are you
talking about how many people how many
people protested uh uh during the summer
of Love riots 20,000 across the country
I don't know how big they were I was it
in every one no way they were in every
city in every single City all the major
ones right 500,000 people they had
people in kosha they
so about 500,000 people oh you said
500,000 more
more I guess there could be that's how
many how many soldiers are in the US
Armed Forces a million something yeah
there's there's like just just over a
million if that I don't know what they
are now because of uh retention why was
it that far-left extremists were able to
shut down a police precinct in Seattle
and take control of an entire
neighborhood because the government in
charge of Seattle agreed with the
protesters but it's not just the
government I mean the people have to
support an uprising don't they the
people have to support an uprising but
you also aren't going to have an
uprising without levels of government
supporting it we keep talking about you
know the Confederacy and all these other
things what about revolutions
revolutions don't have government
supporting it they just have the people
supporting it I mean this is you know
I'm I'm talking about what I learned
from what's his name shuer or whatever
you know like you have to have the
people's support in order to conduct a
revolution I'm not dismissing do you
know what the uh the principal factor in
Revolution
is the number one cause lack of bread
yeah yeah lack of food lack of lack of
bread so when uh what's the guy's name
uh uh uh which which re haslov or
whatever hierarchy of needs you know
what I'm talking about oh maslo maslov
there you go I I couldn't get the first
one I was trying to think which
Revolution are we talking have love but
he's the one with the dog dogy do so
when people don't have food shelter or
security their nervous systems
erupt the cost of milk
increased from 21 to 22
15.2% and uh the cost of milk is going
up every year eggs are still expensive
eggs are still expensive ridiculously
expensive right what are they at it's
like $799 holy I mean those are the
nice organic ones oh okay okay but like
still wow I did I did buy fancy eggs I I
did buy some non-fancy eggs I got half a
dozen for three bucks no wife does the
organic thing too yeah only knows we're
Civil War may have this thin veneer of
some kind of political or ideological
cause but the real reason people will go
out in the street and firebomb is
unrelated like the reason we got the
Summer of Love had nothing to do with
George Floyd it had to do with people
being locked in their homes smelling
like unable to go outside getting
no sunlight decaying by force they were
not allowed to leave I mean you kind of
were but everybody's in their cubicle
New York apartment rotting away and
they're losing their minds and the
excuse to be able to go outside was and
an excuse was made that's what happened
and exactly K it because people just
wanted to go out and up the
day before George Floyd was killed on
May 24th 2020 we had been in lockdowns
whatever you know my son and I had been
at my mom's uh you know in her like far
away house and then we came back and it
was like a beautiful spring day it was
gorgeous May Spring New York it was
spectacular we lived in Brooklyn took
the ferry to Manhattan we walked all the
way up town it was like yes the city
will come back the city is great people
were hanging out it was gorgeous and we
were so heartened and hopeful you know
went to the favorite Cafe got some
sandwiches there was actually a little
mold on the bread we didn't tell the guy
because you know like I'm just glad that
you exist still and you didn't get shut
down and um the very next day it was a
beautiful spring day it was gorgeous the
very next day was Central Park Karen the
lady with the bird watcher oh wow that
oh gosh yeah that was May 25th that
night George was George Floyd the video
emerged and by the weekend everything
that was hopeful about New York City was
trashed under these protesters feet
because it it's no coincidence that it
was 10 weeks to the day that New York
City went into lockdown and that it was
just gorgeous out I mean it was it was
beautiful thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net